beaucoup de réactions d'abord sur la
conférence de presse de joe biden
puisqu'en fait à la toute fin de cette
conférence de presse il ya eu une passe
d'armes entre le président américain et
une journaliste de cnn avec
vraisemblablement une question qui a
plutôt des plus au locataire de la
maison blanche qui a répondu de manière
assez sèche à la journaliste la
polémique était en train d'enfler si
bien que juste avant de prendre l'avion
air force one
joe biden a pris le soin d'aller voir
les journalistes qui étaient présents
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport pour leur
préciser qu'il souhaitait présenter ses
excuses à cette journaliste qu'il
n'aurait pas dû se comporter comme ça
voilà donc pour la petite anecdote à la
suite de cette conférence de presse de
joe biden une conférence de presse où on
l'a vu les questions avaient été
soumises au préalable ces jo bayal lui
même qui appelait les les reporter à
poser leurs questions on notera aussi
qu'il n'y avait pas de journalistes
russes par exemple qui étaient présents
à cette conférence de presse alors en
tout cas sur la teneur des discussions
et des différentes annonces qui ont été
faites cet après midi finalement ça pas
vraiment convaincu ceux qui étaient
contre c'est ce sommet le sont toujours
on a notamment des élus et des
représentants républicains qui
critiquent la position de joe biden qui
les accuse de ne pas avoir fait preuve
d'assez de fermeté face à vladimir
poutine et puis à l'inversé démocrates
eux récupèrent la rhétorique de joe
biden en mettant en avant
justement les dossiers sensibles qu'il a
pu aborder avec le président russe
on a eu aussi le droit toute la journée
à l'analyse des images de la gestuelle
par les médias américains notamment cnn
qui analysait donc tous les faits et
gestes des deux présidents pendant leurs
différentes rencontres avec parfois des
choses qui n'étaient pas très honnête
parce qu'on avait des captures d'écran
notamment qui étaient postés sur les
réseaux sociaux de la part de
journalistes de cnn
par exemple pour expliquer que vladimir
poutine avait détourné le regard au
moment de la poignée de mains avec joe
biden ou encore pour dire que
l'atmosphère était lourde dans la salle
où on a pu voir les deux présidents la
salle qui avait été ouverte à la presse
alors qu'en réalité lorsqu'on voyait
l'intégralité des images on s'apercevait
que l'ambiance était bien différente à
celle qui était présentée par donc les
médias notamment les journalistes de cnn
plus généralement les médias ici aux
etats unis son vous savez assez clément
avec joe biden sur l'autre sur la
plupart de sa politique et notamment sur
sa politique internationale je vous
propose de regarder ce se récupérer
quelques récapitulatif pardon des médias
juste avant le
sommet qu'avaient été organisée en 2018
entre donald trump et vladimir poutine à
helsinki et le sommet qui a eu lieu cet
après midi vous allez voir la rhétorique
est complètement différente voire même
opposé le président d'haydn essaie
d'être non seulement la voix la plus
forte contre l'autoritarisme dans le
monde mais également le meilleur exemple
de la raison pour laquelle le modèle
autoritariste est défaillante
il ne s'agit pas de conclure des accords
mais de fixer les limites avec la russie
selon mbaye donné ses conseillers
l'objectif est de regarder poutine droit
dans les yeux vous venez d'assister à ce
qui est sans doute la pire prestation
d'un président des états unis lors d'un
sommet face à un dirigeant russe
ce que je n'ai jamais vu une conférence
de presse
hors du commun je pense que les
américains n'ont encore jamais vu de
conférence de presse de la sorte entre
un président américain et un dirigeant
russe décrit par tous nos alliés comme
mon adversaire est un adversaire
dangereux
vous voyez le traitement médiatique et
très différents entre joe biden et
donald trump est d'ailleurs les équipes
de la maison blanche ont vraiment pris
le soin de ne pas organiser de
conférence de presse conjointe entre joe
biden et vladimir poutine justement pour
éviter les critiques des médias à
l'époque contre l'ancien président des
états unis